it's over for Donald Trump right guys I
mean at some point it's time to just
admit that it's not gonna happen for the
guy he gets caught with this video and
audio talking a billy bush about how
sometimes you just got to grab women by
the [ __ ] and then he tries to say well
Bill Clinton's done worse is if Bill
Clinton's even running for anything it
makes absolutely no sense it's
incoherent Paul Ryan says no Trump at my
event he's completely distanced himself
John Kasich of Ohio Republican governor
former presidential candidate the one
remotely rational guy who ran for
president on the Republican side says
I'm flat-out not voting for Donald Trump
we are starting to see now the
Republican start to think about can we
even get this guy out at all and people
are talking about rule 9 the my
understanding of the situation is as
follows if Donald Trump decides to back
out of this race then rule 9 is the
process by which Republicans could
decide who to replace Trump with now
it's really not even worth talking about
for two reasons number one if they end
up replacing Trump it won't matter who
they replace him with this thing is over
okay just it's over period it's done
number two Trump has said he's not
backing out and he's not going to get
out of this thing and I guess I take him
at his word I don't even know why the
guys lied about everything under the Sun
but I guess I believe that he's staying
in this thing until the end this at this
point is not even a race and I am so
eager to get back to the studio after
the weekend and after the debate and who
knows what's going to happen tomorrow
night and hear from the apologists how
is it that this isn't going to have an
impact and you know what the truth is
Donald Trump's policy ideas should be
way more concerning than the fact that
he seems to hold women in pretty low
regard and thinks that because he's
famous he can just touch them or do
whatever he wants to them whenever he
wants the policy prescriptions and I
hesitate to even call him that I'm using
that term loosely should concern is way
more than this but this is going to have
an impact because when you step back for
a second and say
are we going to elect a leader of the
free world who is on tape making such
ridiculous and absurd comments about
women I don't see it sean hannity last
night did this just embarrassing
apologetics where he said listen King
David had 500 concubines which I mean
the entire idea of this defense is
ridiculous but if you not that I care
about this but for those who actually
study the history of biblical David his
actions with regard to women are sort of
like the one thing that typically you
don't try to defend and sean hannity
having to dig very very deep in that
satchel of retrograde and depraved
talking points for this one in order to
find some way to defend Trump it's over
if you disagree explain to me exactly
why not because at this point the path
for Trump was uphill and this isn't
going to help him take Florida back from
Hillary Clinton this isn't going to help
him retain Ohio and if he can't win both
of those the path to 270 electoral votes
at